hello believe nation welcome to a quick
hangout uh this morning I got asked in
my mastermind group from one of my
members how do I find my one word and
she wrote in to say she thinks at its
shine as shine let's use all her gifts
she loves the idea of the light shining
she says as a child she wanted to
overcome dark with light hatred with
love she wanted to be able to express
herself when she felt China was the best
version of that she sees what I'm doing
with believe and is trying to find her
one word I thought this could be helpful
for all you guys as well to figure out
what you stand for a little bit of
context to start off with because I
believe everybody has one word that they
stand for and when you figure out what
that one word is your life and your
business will change and it's not just
from marketing it's not just how you
promote yourself but it's who you
surround yourself with the team that you
attract yourself to the products and
services that you launched when I
accompanied and embraced believe as my
one word my business started to take off
my video started doing insanely better I
started attracting the right people into
my team I started launching products
that made sense for people and people
really embraced and so I'm a huge
believer in it and I'm gonna give you a
quick method to how to figure out your
one word the first step is you think
about what makes you happy what are the
things that make you come alive what are
the things that you love doing and you
just don't even think about what your
one word is yet just think about all the
things that you love doing things you
could do all day long and things that
fill your life with joy write those
things down and this isn't just a
business thing this is you personally
because you want to make this personal
for your business to be successful the
second thing is then look at what
connects them what are all the things
that connect those things that make you
happy
what's the connective tissue and try to
figure out is there one word that can
bring all those things together so think
about what your favorite movie is your
favorite book your favorite your best
friend growing up what you love about
your parents you know what businesses
you've been attracted to the hobbies
that you love doing what connects them
all together for me it's belief you know
I love Seabiscuit as a movie which is
about this under
horse in underdog jockey an underdog
trainer
underdog owner and how they all work
together to then win a whole bunch of
races the songs I listen to are always
the uplifting believe kind of positive
ones those are the ones that I gravitate
towards what I love about my parents is
that they always believed in me and told
me that I was a Christian Carmichael and
I could do anything that I wanted even
if they didn't give me them the ideas I
had a sort of business they always
believed that whatever I could did I
would be successful at and taught me to
believe in myself
and so it's really important and so all
of those things that I've done across my
life have been about believe and when I
encompass that it allowed me to start
living my life on purpose with direction
instead of just being reacting to it so
right they're all a list of things that
you love in your life and then try to
figure out what connects them if you
can't figure out what you're one where
it is or you have a couple of them then
go negative think about the people who
you can't stand in your life what are
the the traits in individuals that might
be around you that you just absolutely
hate and for me it's somebody who is
negative right like haters I hate haters
I hate I hate people who tell me that I
can't do something and I hate people who
put other people down basically the
opposite of belief and sometimes that
you find it easier to find your one
where if I finding the negative of what
you don't stand for what you don't like
the next thing to think about is this
fourth part is it's a constant this has
always been a part of your life it's
always been who you are and will always
be who you are it's not some passing
trend some fad that you're interested in
it's always been a part of this you look
back on your life five ten years ago I
was still about believe in five ten
years I still would be about believe so
try to remember your life back and think
how was I like before and one of the
things that were important to me then
that are still important to me now that
connective tissue is encompassing of
your one word and the last part is be
real you want to make sure that it's not
just something that you're trying to be
like it's your ideal it's the I wish I
was this person right it's the person
who you actually are right but lie to
yourself the easiest verse to lie to is
your
self and make sure there's something
that is actually genuine and authentic
so what makes you happy what connects
them go- what's been a constant
throughout your entire life and then
make sure that you're being real some of
the objections that people often face
when they're trying to create their one
word you think it's too simple well
that's the idea it's one word it's
supposed to be simple right believe is
simple when I first wrote down the ideas
that I have for what I stood for what I
wanted my business to be about I had
things like believe in yourself believe
it's possible and a whole bunch of other
sentences I thought believe it's up with
two simple and the more I sat on it the
more I felt like ah you know what this
is this is what I really stand for this
is much more powerful and what I want to
be all about the next one is people
think it's too bold and again it's
supposed to be bold right this is
supposed to be something that inspires
you that motivates you that attracts
people to you that help you launch
products or services around it it helps
you live a life that is meaningful
impactful will help change the world and
help you start to think outside of your
kind of ordinary life and think that I
can have a major impact and so if you
want to inspire people you have to have
a word that is ball that is inspiring
that is powerful
the third objection or question I get is
what do you think and this is what my
mask my member asks me what do I think
and nobody can tell you you're one word
right like I can't tell you what your
one word should be it's up to you to
figure that out and these are giving you
kind of the tools to have it go about
doing that but you should not be looking
to other people for approval on what is
core to you if this is what is this is
who you are this is what you're gonna
build a business around then it's got to
come from a place where you look
yourself in the mirror and you're happy
with it and you should not need the
approval of other people to say yes
that's who you are you can maybe solicit
feedback in the pins and ideas but in
the day it's got to be you making the
decision and then the last point is
people often say well someone else is
using it if it's a bold powerful strong
word other people will be using it
that's okay
belief has been used countless times
it's been used in movies news and songs
just
bieber has his whole belief thing going
on that's okay right everybody can put
their own stamp on it I'm the guy who
believes in entrepreneurs and I've
created my own stink what I encourage
you to do is after you have your
definition once you have your figure
what your word is there are the three
things that it means to you so for me I
want people to believe in what they're
doing right I want people to be
passionate about the work that they're
doing right you have to believe in a
product service that you're creating I
also want people to believe in
themselves that's what most people think
about when they think about the word
believe is that self confidence and then
I want people to believe that it's going
to work out that even if you only see
darkness right now that it will work out
that there is light somewhere there at
the end of the tunnel it will work out
for you and so those are the things that
I find really helps me so for my master
I remember who wrote in you know she was
saying that light is important shining
is important she wants people to be
encouraged to use other gifts it was
something that she always liked as a
child and still likes now she wants to
use it as a inspirational message to
express yourself so these are all the
right things these are all the things
that are super important that I think
help make up a meaningful one work for
your business what I think you'll find
is the more you sit on it the more you
like it that's what I found for my one
ward right I started with this whole
list of ideas and the more lifted
believe the more I liked it the more I
wanted to do it the more it felt right
and after about a week of thinking about
it and every day getting better and
better and more comfortable with it I
did it I needed a small test and it
worked out I need another small test I
start with my newsletter then I started
with making videos and then slowly and
company encompassed it into my entire
business and so sleep on it sleep on it
again sleep on it again and if it's the
right word for you it should be
something that with time becomes more
and more and more and more and more
comfortable I knew this is a live stream
as a test to some people watching so hey
guys writing prophets writing in I love
your videos man thank you bro I've been
sharing your content with my audience a
lot lately keep up the great work really
appreciate that man and little satoshi
writing in hey Evan denote I Lopez what
do you think of him I don't know him
well we're doing a top 10 video of him
so we've done a little bit of research
but I'm not a subscriber as his and I
haven't followed much of his video so I
know he's a really controversial
character some people love them some
people think is a scam artist so that's
all I got sorry man
so thank you guys for watching that's my
input on the one word good luck to my
mastermind member and love to know what
you guys say leave a comment below
thanks for watching continue to believe
have a great Monday and I will see you
soon